So, one week ago, I received an email from SoundCloud, an important notice regarding a violation. One of our tracks was for Antibene breach of their terms of use. The track in breach was Case 26, Lisa Marie Young. To be honest, I didn't even read their email properly, because straight away I thought that's the only episode that we play a full song on. The beautiful track written and performed by Lisa's friend, Alison Crowe, titled of Lisa's song.
一周前，我收到了一封来自SoundCloud的电子邮件，这是一份关于违规的重要通知。我们的一首曲目因违反了他们的使用条款而被下架。违规的曲目是第26案，丽莎·玛丽·杨（Lisa Marie Young）。老实说，我当时并没有仔细阅读邮件，因为我立刻想到那是我们唯一播放完整歌曲的一集。那首优美的曲目是由丽莎的朋友艾莉森·克罗（Alison Crowe）创作并演唱的，名为《丽莎之歌》（Lisa's song）。
I assumed that was the issue. SoundCloud realised there was a song played on the podcast and they believed there might be a copyright issue or something. So I replied to the email and didn't think too much more of it. I knew we had full permission to use the song and I thought it wouldn't take long to sort the issue out. A few days passed and I still hadn't heard anything back from SoundCloud and the track was still down.
我以为问题出在这里。SoundCloud意识到播客中播放了一首歌，他们认为可能存在版权问题之类的。所以我回复了邮件，没再多想。我知道我们有使用这首歌的完整授权，以为很快就能解决这个问题。几天过去了，我仍然没有收到SoundCloud的任何回复，而且那首曲目依然处于下架状态。
So I mentioned it to a friend, who I then showed the email to. He pointed out that I was completely wrong. The violation had nothing to do with the use of a song. I'll quote directly from the email. One of your tracks has been found to be in breach of our terms of use on the grounds of violating an individual's right of privacy slash publicity without their prior consent. The tracking question is Case 26, Lisa Marie Young. So that changed things a little bit.
于是我向一位朋友提到了这件事，并给他看了那封邮件。他指出我完全搞错了。违规行为与歌曲的使用毫无关系。我直接引用邮件的内容：您的其中一个曲目被发现违反了我们的使用条款，理由是在未经个人事先同意的情况下侵犯了其隐私权或公开权。有问题的曲目是第26案，丽莎·玛丽·杨。所以情况发生了一些变化。
If I had actually read the email properly to begin with, I would have realised earlier. So I got in contact with SoundCloud again, requesting more information. One individual was making this complaint. What are the specifics of the complaint? You know, give me some more information, SoundCloud. Something. It didn't make any sense to me at all. All the information from that episode was found online, so it had to be publicly available
如果我一开始就认真阅读了邮件，我本可以更早意识到这一点。所以我再次联系了SoundCloud，要求提供更多信息。是一个人提出了投诉。投诉的具体内容是什么？你知道，SoundCloud，给我更多信息吧。什么都行。这对我来说完全说不通。那一集的所有信息都是在网上找到的，所以它们一定是公开可用的。
already. Otherwise I wouldn't have found it. I still haven't heard anything back from SoundCloud at all. So then I woke up this morning to find out that complaints had also been made to Stitcher and iTunes. However, as they don't host the actual files, the complainant was directed to where we host. The complaint was then forwarded onto me. The complaint says, quote,
否则我根本找不到。我至今仍未收到SoundCloud的任何回复。今天早上醒来时，我发现Stitcher和iTunes也收到了投诉。然而，由于他们并不托管实际的文件，投诉人被引导至我们托管文件的平台。投诉随后被转发给了我。投诉内容引用如下：
They do not have my permission to use my name in the audio file and to publicly announce my name along with my birthdate. It is illegal to do what they did, to list my birthday, name and city and my charges, which are not public information. The complaint came from a person who gave the name Chris. The time codes given in the complaint match the times I talk about Christopher Adair, driver of the Red Jaguar, the man who Lisa left the party with, after which she was never seen again.
“他们没有得到我的许可在音频文件中使用我的名字，并公开宣布我的名字和出生日期。他们所做的事情是非法的，列出我的生日、姓名、城市以及我的指控，这些都不是公开信息。”这份投诉来自一个自称克里斯（Chris）的人。投诉中给出的时间码与我谈论克里斯托弗·阿代尔（Christopher Adair）的时间相吻合，他是那辆红色捷豹的驾驶员，也是丽莎离开派对后与之同行的人，此后她就再也没有出现过。
So he is the last known person to see her alive. I emphasise last known person. We aren't making any accusations. And the information about his record that he's complaining about actually came from the Government of British Columbia Court Services online website, justice.gov.bc.ca.cso.index.do. It's right there free for anyone to search for and find, a government website. The website states the information is available to the public to ensure an open and transparent judicial process in order to preserve public confidence in the courts and the administration
所以他是最后已知见到她活着的人。我强调是“最后已知见到的人”。我们并没有做出任何指控。而他所投诉的关于他记录的信息，实际上来自不列颠哥伦比亚省政府法院服务在线网站，justice.gov.bc.ca.cso.index.do。任何人都可以免费搜索并找到它，这是一个政府网站。该网站声明，这些信息可供公众查阅，以确保司法程序的公开透明，从而维护公众对法院和司法行政的信心。
of justice. So a search comes up with Christopher Adair's year of birth, charges, name and city. We don't actually give his birthdate in the episode, just his year of birth. The website says the court record information may be used without permission for public information and research, provided the material is accurately reproduced. We acknowledge the website as a source in the show notes. We don't say anything that wasn't there in black and white on the site. Information we came across while researching this case.
因此，搜索结果显示了克里斯托弗·阿代尔的出生年份、指控、姓名和城市。我们实际上并没有在节目中给出他的出生日期，只给出了出生年份。网站称，法院记录信息可在未经许可的情况下用于公共信息和研究，前提是材料被准确复制。我们在节目说明中承认该网站为来源。我们没有说任何网站上没有黑纸白字写明的内容。这些是我们研究此案时发现的信息。
If it was in fact Christopher Adair who made this complaint, I didn't realise he was a listener of the show. We did try and contact him for comment at the time we were researching the case, but we couldn't get in touch. So I would like to extend an offer for him to come on and have his say. We would be more than happy to make that happen any time. Also, we will be closing our Seattle Cloud account completely. There is nothing that they offer that can't be done on our website, casefoldpodcast.com.
如果确实是克里斯托弗·阿代尔提出了这项投诉，我没想到他还是节目的听众。我们在研究此案时确实尝试联系他征求意见，但没能联系上。因此，我想邀请他来节目中发表自己的看法。我们非常乐意随时安排。此外，我们将彻底关闭我们的SoundCloud账户。他们提供的功能在我们的网站casefoldpodcast.com上都能实现。
Episodes can be streamed and MP3 files downloaded directly from our website. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目可以在我们的网站上直接在线收听，也可以下载MP3文件。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。